i want to talk about tyler perry and i
want to talk about the man i want to
talk with the mind yeah
did you ever get [ __ ] flustered
with us for sure man okay to walk into
these rooms and sit with white folks and
and try to get them to understand and
and fighting and battling with them and
then come out and then have us say no
he's a [ __ ] in the buffoon why's [ __ ]
got on the dress what's he doing why is
this why you know and when i'm hearing
all this noise man it was crazy because
there were no black people on television
before diversity became a thing tyler
perry was the only one out there for a
long time there was a moment where every
movie that after the 90s where i had all
these black hits everything stopped for
a minute ever all these when the cw and
wb merged all those black shows went
away and i was the only one out there
and what i found out is that people take
shots at the deer they can see nobody
else was doing anything so here i am in
this moment okay what are you going to
do tyler you're trying to get somewhere
you got to focus you know exactly what
you want to do you're going to listen to
this noise and let them talk you out of
what you know is yours by the way as
you're winning yeah as you're winning
every time as you're winning every time
we're talking about noise that's coming
in
as you're winning yeah we're not talking
about
noise to the fail which of course is a
different type of noise we're talking
about noise that's coming in as you're
knocking down barriers as you're doing
the unconventional for us yes as you're
creating
creating different pipelines of revenue
uh building so my whole foundation so i
can get to this studio ownership so all
of it was a part of it so i had to keep
my eye on that up there you got all this
noise here i see i see but yeah i hear
y'all but i'm saying right here because
i'm looking up there and when i think
about somebody who i love dearly was
whitney and i did all i could to try and
help her man with houston
she i i believe she still would have
been alive today
had
we not
tried to make her into something she
wasn't
her being booed at the soul train award
was awards with one of the worst things
that could have happened to her in her
life
her people saying she's white or she's
this so she's that made her want to show
because you know these her she came to
this industry very young but it made her
want to show that she was something
different
instead of just realizing let me keep my
eye on this because she's got the best
voice in the world if she had kept her
eye on that none of this other stuff
would have mattered
it's the curse of trying to prove yes
right and i think you know uh
you're no
you're no better and i know better um
than
than being a victim
of the curse of trying to prove it's
very hard
to avoid
the world of trying to prove hold on
what yeah i don't think i cause i
who you talk yeah cause don't get it
[ __ ] up for one minute i can't it's a
it's a thing right um and and the crazy
thing
that i think
we have to deal with or some of us have
to deal with is finding a way to
compartmentalize that
keep that at bay
and stay on the course and look at the
good that's happening on the course
because this makes you
this makes you [ __ ] look over here
and you for a second you stop you you
stop looking at all the great here i
learned the hard way man i learned the
hard way it's like driving the car and
the things are going so well it's 100
miles an hour but you keep looking down
here to see what's going on you're going
to run into something
instead of getting to the destination
because by time you get to the
destination all of that noise none of it
matters all those people who are talking
trying to get it doesn't matter because
i've seen the very same people who were
my worst critics come and say hey man oh
my god this is amazing wow
it's amazing wow look what you did how'd
you do it how'd you do it actually i did
it because i ignored your ass right i
kept moving
you